so kevin mccarthy the
house minority leader is going to have a
full week of
q anon and jewish space lasers on his
hands
apparently you know he went down last
week and he uh kissed the ring of trump
uh took a nice little stage picture of
him and his his bro standing with each
other
as he went down to make sure that trump
was not gonna kick him out of the party
i guess
now that it's officially trump's party
since kevin mccarthy went down to
mar-a-lago to
to suckle at the magatit
we find out that marjorie taylor greene
the jewish
space laser lady the cue and honor
all the stuff that this crazy lady
believes
she was on the phone with trump on the
phone with um instead of time
in in politics when the republican party
is crumbling and trump's gonna
piss on the ashes here so kevin mccarthy
flies down the mar-a-lago have a nice
little conversation with old trumpy bear
and make sure that he can hold the party
together
because it's all falling apart in the
house and the senate
i mean you have you have guys like matt
gatz
this [ __ ] lunatic he flies all the
way out to wyoming
stands in front of a microphone acts
like he's running for the president
of wyoming or something i don't know
what the hell he's doing in wyoming
he's trying to campaign against liz
cheney
i mean we're we're not even into
we're just into february in 2021 and we
have republicans
flying out to wyoming to campaign
against liz
cheney this is where they're at i mean
this [ __ ] is damn near
burnt down to the ground if that's where
we're at
all at the same time kevin mccarthy is
begging trump to keep the party together
because there's word of all these
parties splintering off the patriot
party
uh there's another party that uh david
jolly a former
house representative from florida he
wants to start a separate party
uh a more inclusive party
a big tent type party you know like a
democratic party
but they they want to splinter this
republican party into a hundred
different groups which i'm all for
i really think we should do that we
should absolutely let the republican
party
splinter itself into a hundred different
groups here fantastic
fantastic absolutely fantastic with the
way that th
that these districts are gerrymandered
nothing would be better for democrats
than for these people to split off
into different parties and chop up the
vote fantastic if you have five people
running
in a district and you're gonna break up
the republican
the conservative the white christian
vote
fantastic let's chop that up a million
times let's do that
let's do that but kevin mccarthy's
trying to hang on to his party here
trying to hang on to his house
conference
because he he wants to remain the
minority leader
because this buffoon has no idea what
he's doing
no [ __ ] clue what he's doing and it's
obvious
and that's why he's going down to kiss
the ring of donald trump to hold it all
together
in the meantime he's supposed to have a
talk with this
this jewish space laser
uh sandy hook denying [ __ ]
marjorie taylor green supposed to have a
talk with her this week
about her views on q and on and holding
it down a little bit
keep it down a bit all the while he's
praising her on phone calls wanting
and praising her for the 175 000 that
she raised because that's really why
they want this lady that's really why
they want her to
keep um keep on with this q anon stuff
is because
these people hand over their cash
that's a thing that they do and i'm
talking about the
the q anon believers out there not the
politicians i'm talking
about the believers they hand over that
money
money money money it's a money machine
let's do that
so kevin mccarthy tries to make right
with trump
and he's gonna have a talking to with
marjorie taylor green all the while
marjorie taylor green
is i don't know if they're sexting or
what they're doing
her and trump apparently they're calling
each other back and forth she's talked
to him several times
she plans on making an overnight trip
down to mar-a-lago
i don't know if melania trump knows
about this but
someone better notify her new press
office
that marjorie taylor green is moving in
and she's gonna go visit him on a
regular basis
and she claims she claims that trump
supports her 100 percent which i
completely believe
i completely believe that he supports
this nonsense 100 percent
i mean she'll absolutely believe
anything that has anything to do with
making a trump a god
and that's a good thing for him he's
like yeah let's let's do that
let's believe that let's have that all
the while splintering this party even
even in the finer pieces which is fine
by me hopefully
hopefully by the end of the summer these
dumb [ __ ] will be reduced to
salt dust
uh they they're chopped up so much and
we're getting there i mean we had the
q anon the q guy apparently outed uh
there's a lot of reports of who the q
guy actually is i don't believe any of
this [ __ ]
by the way i don't believe any any one
person is cue i think that's
more nonsense than the actual [ __ ] that
they that they type into the internet
uh if you if you believe if you believe
that q is one person and one person
perpetuated all this stuff i got i got a
[ __ ] ton of jewish space lasers that i'd
like to sell you
i really really would [ __ ] them